attention aux t il est un petit peu
chaud alors mon petit demain nous avons
voulu de parler avec maintenant il faut
tout d'abord que tu saches que nous ne
sommes pas là pour te juger d'accord
d'accord
thomas ne le bouscule pas trop quand tu
rentres à la maison tu as les yeux
bizarres regarde nous quand on te parle
ça les regarde et nous arrive pas me
faire honte
qu'est ce qui s'est passé et surtout qui
fait pas ça tout seul mais sa maman un
jeu rien fait de mal moi retire tes
lunettes
d'accord bravo mamie c'est un carnage
eh bien quoi qu'est ce qu'il ya boitant
quoi tu en train de ta grand mère
ça va on n'est pas ensemble à toutes les
séances non plus voilà les séances de
quoi c'est un stock quoi oui c'est pas
si grave
le grand écran va vous en mettre plein
les yeux
la fête du cinéma du dimanche 26 au
mercredi 29 juin 4 euros la séance
mais tu t'es regardez qu'est ce qu'il ya
merci venez au ciné et partez en voyage
avec le grand jeu fête du cinéma
vous serez toujours inspiré par le
cinéma d'été paribas prolongement faire
du cinéma du 30 juin au 6 juillet
deux cent mille contre marque à 4 euros
à gagner bnp paribas la banque d'un
monde qui change